another kind of symbol that was very
popular especially in the later Middle
Ages is something known as magic squares
these were as the name suggests squares
in which various numbers or sometimes
letters representing numbers were
written into separate columns big deal
you may think well the thing about magic
squares is that they are always designed
so that if you add up the numbers in any
of the rows whether horizontally
vertically or diagonally you will always
end up with the same number number these
kinds of squares again were thought to
be very powerful for Magical purposes
the earliest and most popular form of
magic square was the 3X3 variant as it
was obviously the easiest to make the
3X3 magic square was also called by the
name Budu later more complex magic
squares were developed 4x4 and even 6x6
and Beyond which of course made them
even more powerful